mariam pougetoux présidente de l'unef
incendie un syndicat étudiant à la
sorbonne à paris est actuellement en
train de vivre une énorme polémique
autour d'elle la jeune femme est apparue
samedi dernier voilée dans le 19 45 de
m6 et cette séquence a fait énormément
réagi en effet donc l'image de cette
jeune fille a directement été partagés
sur les réseaux sociaux est relié par
des personnes pour qui le voile pose
problème à l'origine du scandale
c'est laurent bouvet cofondateur du
mouvement printemps républicains qui
avaient publié sur facebook à l'unef la
convergence des luttes est bien entamée
c'est la présidente du syndicat à
l'université paris-sorbonne kg dit avant
d'être repris par beaucoup d'internautes
s'en est suivi donc un défouloir sur
twitter voilà avec des messages très dur
il ya des gens également bien sûr qu'ils
ont soutenus mariam pougetoux on va voir
l'extrait j'aime j'aime pas alors
benjamin castaldi vous vous trouvez que
c'est exagéré
ah oui et même aussi et isabelle elle
est plus voilà mais elle est plus
modérée là dessus alors et vous
christine je crois que vous êtes vous
allez me donner votre avis aussi entre
les deux aussi regarder l'extrait on en
parlait il étudiants réclament plus de
moyens et la création de 66 me classe
supplémentaire à la rentrée
universitaire 2010 9 mais surtout
l'abandon du nouveau système de
sélection dans les universités on veut
un enseignement pour toutes et tous et
de manière livré à l'université qu'on
laisse à la chance aux étudiants les
autres chantent de pouvoir faire ce
qu'ils veulent et de par exemple décider
des capacités d'accueil des universités
en fonction du marché du travail
alors voilà cette jeune fille s'est
retrouvée dans le 19 45 de m6 malgré
elle parce qu'ils ont dû aller à la
sortie et voilà ils ont pris une
personne voilà au hasard pour parler de
ça benjamin castaldi j'aime j'aime pas
une minute trente et juste après vous
allez voir on a la vidéo de denis
brogniart 1 qui a répondu sur la
polémique koh lanta alors je ne parle
pas de la main ces parties communes et
les troubles et mick parce que je pense
qu'il faut essayer d'apaiser les
tensions
d'abord moi je suis très légaliste il
n'est pas interdit porter de voile à
l'université
bien sûr la première chose donc je pense
que c'est pas la peine d'en faire tout
un pataquès maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est une organisation qui censé être
laïque donc effectivement il ya un
décalage entre ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
porte et ce qu'elle me représentais mais
honnêtement je pense que par les temps
qui courent et les récents événements le
prouve il est grand temps d'arrêter de
s'emporter sur tout et sur n'importe
quoi à la loi de porter le voile c'est
c'est la loi il n'y a pas de problème
là-dessus en sincèrement qu'il faut
arrêter et apaiser les esprits et les
consciences
mais on peut lui faire faire et faire un
pas vers l'autre voilà quelle que soit
la religion
isabelle moi je vraiment il était avant
d'accepter ce débat parce que c'est
tellement difficile d'être serein et je
déteste la violence qu'il ya autour
en revanche moi je me souviens j'en veux
passer deux jeunes femmes j'en veux à
l'unef ne l'union des étudiants de
france que je n'aime pas du tout j'ai
jamais aimé qu avec qui je me suis
souvent pris de quoi les autres fois
messi parce que moi quand j'étais à la
faculté à saint martin d'hères agronome
il me reprochait justement d'avoir en
croire me disant c'est un signe
extérieur de religion il faut que tu
l'enlèves et j'avais fini par enlever ma
crois et donc je me dis où c'est un
signe religieux et la loi est la même
pour tout le monde
ou ce n'est pas un signe religieux et
sans voix lui va très bien il faut juste
être clair sur la définition
alors donc vous vous dites quoi en fait
donc moi je trouve que c'est la violence
qui est déversée sur cette jeune femme
est absolument immonde mais en revanche
oui il faut être clair si on ya
séparation de la religion et si la
laïcité absolue est la règle doit être
là mais n'aura jamais n'en sais rien à
voir avec ce principe là de résister à
la le droit c'est la loi de porter le
voile à l'université
donc ce n'est pas une question de denis
coderre a dit entre l'état et la
religion non je trouve que c'est
disproportionné alors ou bien nous a
convaincus parce que oui isabella
électeurs un petit peu mitigé on va pas
demander à mes christine kelly
non moi je trouve que ce qui peut
surprendre c'est le fait qu'elle soit
portée à l'antenne et qu'elle représente
un organisme j'ai l'impression que c'est
ce qui choque le téléspectateur et qui a
été hué à quai à qui a été l'outil enfin
la raison du déversoir alors c'est pas
votre avis je vous pensez que les
téléspectateurs se sont se sont un petit
peu insurgé contre ça parce que pose et
que ça les miens mais pourquoi pourquoi
l'aurait pas le droit de représenter non
mais alors je vous rappelle aussi pour
par exemple françois fillon il avait
pendant la campagne une porte parole qui
arrivait la croix et saint pierre merci
pareil un déversement à ce qu'elle
représentait un candidat à la
présidentielle donc un elle est à
l'antenne de effet nintendo
3 elle représente un organisme voilà ce
qui a fait un peu l explosion et c'est
ça qui est un peu tiens peu la cause
gilles c'est benjamin qui m'a convaincu
j'irai même plus loin dans les propos
pour moi c'est de la stigmatisation des
musulmans encore une fois c'est presque
polémique pour moi c'est presque de
l'islamophobie
c'est totalement injuste et totalement
délirant cette jeune femme n'a rien à se
reprocher c'est si on avait battu alors
j'espère je me faire insulter pas
personne parce que moi ça me choque un
petit peu en revanche
pourquoi on dit la vérité parce que dans
un état laïque tout le monde a droit de
pratiquer sa religion son dogme et tout
ça mais en revanche au sec dans un état
laïque ont fait en sorte de ne pas le
montrer de manière outrancière on va
dire et je vous pose une question à vous
un jour dans cette émission est
quelqu'un qui est venu voiler qui voulez
vous avez dit moi j'aime pas les cons
tout le monde peut venir et bien sûr
j'entends ce que vous avez dit
maintenant est-ce que très honnêtement
si l'un de nous chroniqueur demain venez
avec une énorme d'une croix catholique
au sirop cawi normes étoile de david
très honnêtement au niveau des lauriers
feria sur your aucun problème alors je
vous dis il n'y aura aucun problème
et si cette jeune fille avait eu une
énorme croix je pas sûr qu'on aurait eu
en une belle polémique donc je vous le
dise où la tendance est venu exactement
je crois pas cyril et j'aimerais vous
croire mais alors rien ce serait si
j'avais une énorme croix verte la
chaudrée l'assiette vous dirai rien du
tout si vous aviez une énorme croix et
je vous le dis la chaîne dirai rien du
tout et gabon s'ils avaient une personne
voilée auteurs latins sur une personne
avec une kippa et pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs le faire très prochainement
je vous le dis il n'y aura en rond sera
jamais dans ce débat je vous le dis nous
allons vraiment on est ouvert à tous et
je trouve que et moi moi je prends la
personne la pause c'est une jeune fille
elle s'est retrouvée à la sortie de
l'université
elle répond gentiment sa un journaliste
non mais c'est vrai déjà je vous le dis
elle a dû avoir 40 personnes qui lui ont
refusé qu'ils ont refusé de lui répondre
la jeune fille devait répondre gentiment
elle fait fracasser derrière sur l'airé
du jura mais là c'est dégueulasse et et
je vois là je joue je trouve franchement
que moi alors on en parle aujourd'hui
que ça fait une et non politique on ne
devrait même pas en parler
voilà je vous lis il aurait aucun
problème
on voit que dans nos rêves fokker
problème s'il y avait vraiment une
personne avec une énorme croatie mais
zéro problème arrêter de dire
franchement je ne peux pas entendre des
choses pareilles oui et bijoux a pas en
quoi le fait de porter un voile empêche
de prendre des responsabilités bien fait
elle s'engage pour lequel une caution à
une croix ou inzaghi droit d'arrêter m m
la laïcité à toutes les sauces à la loi
a été créé au contraire avec l'esprit
inverse il ya qu'on sortait d'une
période de la france et des
essentiellement chrétienne on écrivait
sept inscrits de laïcité pour que toutes
les religions puissent s'exercer que ce
librement sans qu'ils aient de
stigmatisation et maintenant on fait
l'inversé adobe offert la liste et pour
la bâloise laïcité été créé pour que les
gens puissent porter messi novice
laïcité séparation préféré un félin
verse maintenant elle est très mal tout
ça se complique c'est ce qui serait
dérangeant c'est si quelqu'un
effectivement hyper voilà quoi et qui
profitèrent l'émission pour parler de ça
louis dumas russe et serbe
parce que exactement le lieu maintenant
à voile mais elle a vraiment choisi la
pauvre a lieu à la fédé pour répondre
gentiment fait fracasser derrière je ne
vous aime pas on va voir ce qui vous a
plus convaincu isabelle 56% 55% à jamais
sophie dire un truc ça va merci sophie
vasseur
c'est ce qu'il faut dire quand tu ne
sais pas quoi dire dans cette émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette pauvre interrogeait c'est fou ffu